bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france alors la réunion
de ce soir c'est aussi pour réfléchir à
des moyens d'action contre le passé ni
terre cela signifie qu'on verra les
organisations syndicales dans la rue
c'est prochain samedi aux côtés des
manifestants des gilets jaunes antipas
sanitaire
déjà en tout cas nous pour ce qui
concerne les travailleurs privés
d'emploi et précaires nous on a
interrogé pour l'emploi et pendant ce
temps on n'a toujours pas de réponse
vous savez qu'il ya une obligation de la
recherche d'emploi si un salarié
précaire et privés d'emploi notamment
des secteurs de l'hôtellerie ou delà des
restaurations des secteurs pour lesquels
il faut le pass sanitaires si le clae
d'emploi n'est pas indemnisée hibon
creux refusent ces offres d'emploi là et
ce qui peut être radiés ou non voilà
donc ça pour nous c'est un vrai sujet
d'inquiétude aujourd'hui on sera bien
évidemment et de tous les travailleurs
privés d'emploi qui pourrait être dans
cette situation là bien que la cgt
appelle à se faire vacciner mais pour
nous il faut pas comprendre il faut
plutôt aller convaincre les travailleurs
et y compris les travailleurs privés
d'emploi et précaires et sur la question
de la des manifestations il ya déjà eu
des manifestations la cgt en semaine
notamment
ldd camarades de la santé qui luttent ou
le 6 contre l'intronisation ne sais pas
si ce n'était la cas une rupture
d'égalité d'accès aux services publics
et puis sur les samedis a déjà du
militant cellules et qui qui vont danser
dans ces manifestations moi pour ma part
j'en suis aussi allé à quelques-unes par
exemple sur paris et pour autant est ce
qu a votre avis il peut y avoir
convergence
nous la question c'est celle de la
liberté ii sur la liberté par exemple il
faut savoir de quoi est ce qu'on parle
de liberté individuelle et surtout et
collective il n'y a pas de forcément de
différence d'ailleurs à faire entre les
deux oppositions je prendre un seul
exemple vous savez il ya une forme
d'assurance chômage qui a été annulée
par conseil d'état en tout cas certaine
mesure et que le gouvernement va nous
imposer cette réforme la elvis quoi elle
vise à indemniser moins de priver
d'emploi dire qu'ils vont se retrouver
sans aucune indemnité chômage parce
qu'ils n'auront pas travailler pendant
six mois
ça c'est 600 milles précaire et puis un
million cent cinquante mille
travailleurs précaires verront leurs
indemnités baissé en moyenne de 30%
quand on doit vivre avec 500 euros comme
le rsa ou avec 800 euros qu'on ait
indemnisé à pôle emploi c'est quoi la
liberté et donc non je veux bien la cgt
quand on manifeste pour l'augmentation
des salaires quand on manifeste dans la
réduction du temps de travail un emploi
pour toutes et tous on se bat pour la
liberté dès l'annoncé dans ces moments
là voilà il n'y a pas de la convergence
elle se fait comme ça il se fait sur des
revendications et nous la cgt nos
revendications c'est effectivement le
retrait de l'espace sanitaire là et des
mesures fortes en matière de protection
sociale l'indemnisation de tous les
privés d'emploi et puis en matière
d'emploi parce que le gouvernement j'ai
écouté gabriela talent sur le grand jury
à airtel et il nous dit que il ya une
reprise économique la reprise économique
elle est soit inexistante soit soit très
faible moi je prends les derniers
chiffres de la bns au de second
trimestre 2021 il y avait toujours plus
de 6 7 millions d'inscrits à pôle emploi
c'est en augmentation par rapport au
premier trimestre 2009 interne donc le
gouvernement y manipule les chiffres
tous les chiffres qui peut manipuler une
les manipulent et il essaye de faire
passer le les responsables du chômage
comme étant les chômeurs eux mêmes en
faisant croire à une reprise de l'emploi
alors qu'en réalité c'est le gros point
noir du gouvernement c'est l'emploi si
je prends un peu un seul exemple pour
nos jeunes un tel que l'état est
actionnaire
quand même de renault renault a supprimé
plus de 4600 emplois l'année dernière et
là ils sont en train de laisser les
fonderies ça soit celle de pointe au sel
de bretagne ils sont en train de les
laisser à la merci didier ce soir il ya
plusieurs organisations syndicales qui
se réunissent on vous a parfois vu un
peu divisée est ce que ce sera aussi
l'occasion de parler d'unité face au
combat notamment la rentrée sociale
aussi qui s'annonce
oui oui tout tout tout tout à fait tout
à fait cesser l'unité l'unité dans
l'action comme une fois pour des
revendications parce qu'aujourd'hui il
ya des besoins qui sont ici sont pas
répond notamment celui du droit au
travail celui aussi de comment est-ce
que je signe mon moi parce que le
pouvoir d'achat ne fait que baisser le
gouvernement ne veut pas parler
d'augmentation des salaires quand le
medef parle d'augmentation des salaires
la contrepartie c'est il faut en finir
avec les cotisations sociales qu'ils
appellent charge je rappelle quand même
mystique les cotisations sociales c'est
une part du salaire etc ce
qu'aujourd'hui ce que le gouvernement et
le medef ils ont dans le viseur 7 451
milliards d'euros de cotisations qui
représente une part de notre salaire qui
est indirecte et le gouvernement et le
medef c'est ça qu'ils ont dans le viseur
donc on sera dans la rue pour l'emploi
pour l'augmentation des salaires et puis
pour une protection sociale qui réponde
aux besoins sociaux et à l'urgence
sociale que traverse malheureusement des
millions de travailleurs de notre pays
que je puisque je rappelle que
contrairement à ce que dit le
gouvernement il ya seulement 40 % des
chômeurs inscrits à pôle emploi qui sont
indemnisés quand on n'est pas encore une
fois on doit survivre aux minima sociaux
avec 500 ou 550 euros par mois on
assiste à des semaines de contestation
des samedis consécutifs contre le passé
et à vous n'avez pas peur finalement que
ce combat là il masque d'autres combats
notamment en vue de la rentrée sociale
le gouvernement il utilise la question
du passé militaire effectivement compte
comme un comme un contre-feu à des
réformes antisociales qui en application
déjà depuis plusieurs années ça ne veut
pas dire non plus que les manifestations
contre l'état sanitaire l ont pas ils
n'ont pas un sens enfin là il ya besoin
d'élargir parce qu'effectivement
on a le devoir de lier la question des
libertés et la question des droits
sociaux des droits collectifs des
repères elle ce gouvernement ce qui fait
depuis qu'il est en qu'il est en place
c'est l'igas absolument tous les repères
collectifs les garanties collectives du
droit du travail que ce soit le cd le
recours aux cdd il est laissé aux
branches et les réponses et des méfaits
que d'exploser depuis 20 ans on est
passé de 30 % à 90 % taux d'embauché en
cdd donc c'est inacceptable ils sont en
train de casser le statut de la fonction
publique il classe les services publics
l'industrie est là ils sont en train de
bien prononcer curie sociale donc tous
ces garanties collectives ses droits
collectifs c'est à nous de les recompter
orelsan ou de conquérir ensemble
pour terminer est ce que les à quoi les
français doivent s'attendre ces
prochaines semaines avec la rentrée
sociale est ce qu'elle sera explosive
avec un des greffes peut-être
alors la rentrée sociale bon la cgt
on a eu moins d'actes hic est donc enfin
quand même cet été nous par le
comité des travailleurs prennent très
précaire de lassigny t on est allé à la
rencontre des saisonniers pour leur
expliquer leurs droits aussi pour les
informer de la taxe qui va motivation
venir sobre et puis pour les appeler à
s'organiser et à se battre dans
énormément d'entreprises la durance et a
décrit talent il ya eu des y'a pas un
jour qu'une passion qui est venu des
entreprises là la question qui se pose
qui va se trouver à la rentrée du moins
pour octobre c'est quand on est capable
de construire un processus de lutte pour
qu'on y aille ensemble mais c'est ça
qu'il faut construire ensemble c'est le
blocage de l'économie pour contraindre
le gouvernement à répondre à nos
revendications
merci à pierre garneau dit secrétaire du
comité national cgt des chômeurs et de
précaires